welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to Avengers endgame is the perfect
finale for a franchise that has spanned
22 films over the past 11 years and out
of the 14 million possibilities that
Doctor Strange saw this is by far the
best one that we could have got however
there are still a lot of questions
surrounding the film and throughout this
video I'll be breaking down one of the
main ones that I've seen which is how
did Steve Rogers return the soul stone
throughout this video I'll be discussing
the possible theory surrounding this and
giving my own opinion on it this is full
spoilers ahead so if you haven't seen
Avengers endgame yet and don't want to
know what happens then I highly suggest
that you turn off now with that out the
way thank you for clicking this video I
hope you enjoy it now sit back relax and
let's get into my Steve Rogers mission
explain breakdown at the end of Avengers
and game Steve Rogers journeys back
through the quantum realm in order to
return the Infinity stones for the
specific points that they were snatched
whilst we learn that Steve never
returned and instead remained in the
past till about the rest of his life
with Peggy Carter there are still some
questions that hover over this mission
the main one that I've seen is how did
Steve return the soul stone well there
are several ways and possibilities that
you could have done this the first one
being that Steve is in possession of the
space stone those who've seen the First
Avenger will remember that upon touching
the tesseract red skull was transported
to Boromir in order to act as a guide
for the soul stone with a bit more
knowledge on how the space stone works
Steve could no doubt use this same
method to travel to Boromir and return
the soul stone and use the space one
once more to journey back I would
happily sit through another three hours
to see the meeting of red skull and
Captain America again but I guess that
maybe for another movie
there's also another possibility for
this remember Steve is also in
possession of Mooney Mooney a male
Thor's hammer I don't know how to
pronounce it he's in possession of
Thor's hammer so therefore he has the
ability of flight couple this with
Heimdall's constant watching eye that's
a bit like bran stock who hopefully
isn't the other stock to die this
and he could have been instrumental in
picking him up and bringing him to
Asgard where he could return the hammer
and also rehouse the space stone in the
tesseract with the Asgardians help he
could travel throughout space and
journey back to the soul stone this way
or simply leave it with the Asgardians
to return in the film the Pym particles
are said to give the user a round trip
so this means that Captain America could
have made a full journey to every
dimension that the Avengers traveled to
without having to physically journey
there himself thus meaning that he could
have just walked to each point and each
trip could have just taken an hour this
is probably what most likely happened as
it would have avoided coming into
contact with those that may have caused
the time paradox the most likely journey
would have been first to 2014 to return
the power and soul stone and then 2012
for the mind in time stone before
finally travelling back to 1974 the
space stone where he could have reunited
with Peggy for that final dance which
have seen many people say personally
though judging by the cause and
landscape in that scene I think the 70s
was when Steve grab more Pym particles
and returned to the 1940s
just in time for that final dance that
left everybody crying but not me a
prompt a promise that's just that's just
dust up and that Steve's journey is how
I see it
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on Steve's mission and if you have a
different theory then comment below and
let me know if you love this video 3000
then make sure you give it a thumbs up
and check out my full ending explained
breakdown on the film which would be
linked at the end this is a channel for
people who are super into superheroes so
if that's the kind of thing you like it
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]